[Musique]
on y est trois sur trois après avoir
détaillé les grandes cette cuvée les
ball wenders les grands avec alan les
boilers avec manu on passe évidemment
aux ailiers oui on va détailler
évidemment les différents types de
profils qu'on peut avoir sous cette
appellation mais c'est notre troisième
et dernier podcast de la série des
spécialistes on va dire ce qui nous
permet un petit peu de descendre dans la
cuve et de ne pas parler uniquement des
tops prospère attendu dans la loterie
les wings c'est avec zéro russe avec
hugues comment ça va bah écoute ça va
très content de tout boucler la boucle
après une grosse année chargée
effectivement on est sur la fin on sera
on vous détaillera le programme sur les
réseaux sociaux pour pour le dispositif
du soir de draft mais d'ici là il ya
bien d'autres échéances notamment un
live spécial français à notre live
spécial foire aux questions juste avant
la draft histoire l'histoire d'être
complet histoire que vous soyez prêt
pour jeudi prochain puisque le jeu de la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi ce sera la
draft
les ailiers donc mon cher hughes
on commence par un état des lieux en
état des lieux pas exhaustif mais en nba
pour toi il existe quel type de joueur
est lié qui ont du temps de jeu et
évidemment qu'ils sont cons de la valeur
en fait puisque c'est ça qu'on va
chercher il faut qu'on va aller chercher
dans la draft
ouais le plus répondu qu'on retrouve
c'est ce qu'on appelle communément
maintenant le soulier andy
qui a le plus le profit peut-être le
plus recherché le profil combats souvent
payé d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens
pensaient que ce week end is with était
pour le poste d'ailier il ya eu
tellement un amalgame qui a été fait
assez rapidement et donc des ailiers qui
vont écarter le jeu qui voit de plus
dans un rôle de finition qui vont courir
un petit peu partout et qui vont qui
vont se taper ont restreint de la
défense de l'autre côté moi j'aime bien
aussi ce qu'on appelle les les
engrenages les mecs les ailiers qui vont
fluidifier le jeu qui vont pas des
porteurs de balle initialement mais qui
vont pouvoir lors d'un décalage
récupérer ballon driver qui tient à
ressortir qu'ils disent bien le jeu et
qui sont là pour hurler le moteur à
fluidifier vraiment le jeu et le dernier
chose que j'aime bien aussi c'est les
mecs qui manque parfois tiers métiers
ont compensé par du cut de la pose
d'écrans loin du ballon la bonne
rotation et on va jouer à voir les têtes
les profils surtout pour les jeunes
draft est très athlétique et qui vont
vivre au départ sur leurs qualités
athlétiques
et y tiendra un second temps vont
espérer développer un tir haut niveau
supérieur dans la durée ok donc tu me le
dis ce qu'ils font
détruis ndi donc défenseurs et jouer sur
le poste d'ailier apportant du tir les
fluidifie catr et les quêteurs on va les
appeler les lecteurs les finisseurs
peut-être les athlètes dans ces trois
dans ces trois prototypes l'aller les
plus ceux qui ont le plus de valeur en
nba pour toi et tu es ce que tu peux
donner un exemple de joueurs pour chacun
des prototypes
je pense que
le furent à détroit c'est le fusil
scatter c'est l'engrenage parce qu'un
joueur qui sait tout faire ça va être
très value est un mec alors au départ il
n'était pas là pour ça mais andrew
higgins côté warriors qui était au
départ un athlète une bille ce qui est
une première option un peu fut dit fier
autoporteur qu'on reste dans les
warriors a eu ce rôle de futé fixateur
dans le jeu france wagner qui est drafté
par le magic moi je voyais pas un
créateur du voyage mais qui vraiment
rendait tout le monde meilleur sur
l'autre sur le terrain et donc on est
source de profit là pour le swing and in
a tellement maintenant que récemment
travaillé me fit est ratée l'an dernier
qui était vraiment le profil de ce fait
n 10 et puis au niveau maximum dans ce
registre là le peut-être un des
meilleurs encore un billet ça va
peut-être une propagande aux warriors
parce que ils viennent de gagner un
titre x est clairement les mémoires mais
clyde tolson qui est considéré comme un
all star et de bazin instruit ndi sauf
qu'il l'a fait à un niveau plus plus
plus plus plus et c'est à dire ça qu'on
doit attendre et ça veut pas ça veut pas
forcément dire tape pas de valeur à la
draft mais tu l'aies sur un profil
vraiment de mouvement après pour les
crozes athlètes je vais faire mon humeur
mais un mec comme d'eric jones ignore
par exemple qui au départ n'a pas de
qualité de tir et qui existe là dessus
il a la chance et kuyt sur ses écrans
sur cd marquage et s'est fait une place
dans la grande ligue alors moi j'avais
moi j'aime bien classés les joueurs plus
part par là tu l'as tu les classes parce
qu'ils on va dire moi je en gros les
cutters je l'aimais je vais plus les
mettre dans le podcast ce qu'on a fait
avec alan mais ont toutes façons on n'en
a pas parlé forcément des terry jones on
en a cherché mais n'a pas énormément à
part josh my note dans cette draft
mais
je dirais plus en gros les fleurs
spacer's les boilers et les 14 fin
lecteur screens on va dire pour moi ce
sont les trois rôles qui existent en nba
avec des variables les unes aux autres
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
toi tu penses que le dernier rôle le
type d'eric jones
ça va être quelque chose qui peut être
vrai sur une première partie de carrière
et ensuite se développer sur une seconde
partie de carrière c'est ce que tu
espères pour certains des prospects dont
on a parlé
mois exactement il ya des jours qu'il
faut arriver l'annexion en a beaucoup on
a beaucoup d'ailiers où les gens
espèrent un seuil n 10 mais pour
l'instant n'y a pas le suivre mais ils
ont une très belle lecture de jeu donc
au départ y vont pour pouvoir jouer
faire valoir leurs qualités athlétiques
et dans un second temps ils vont
développer ce tir pour pouvoir pour à
des menaces tester sur le terrain parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est compliqué d'avoir
deux joueurs qui n'ont pas écarté de jeu
qui vont pas tirer à trois points sur
sur ton sac mal gérée sur ses comptes
pivot qui ne tirent pas de loin de ce
comté milwaukee et ces mecs là vont vont
devoir vraiment peaufiné
le tir à trois points
voire avoir un deuxième puis un
troisième contrat surtout un rôle majeur
nba ok
commençons par les les joueurs qu'on va
citer aujourd'hui alors déjà sur sur le
haut de la draft des prospects dont on a
déjà parlé mais
les dans le top 100 dans ton top 5 6
en ailier toi tu ne vois que edge et
griffin est d'accord je n'entends top 5
par an puisque tu as kendall born this
way dans mon top 5 ghz chine qui
persiste parce que j'ai pas envie
d'enterrer les qualités athlétiques du
garçon et qui pour le coup
parmi les cinq jours que j'ai là va être
celui pour lequel j'attends le moins
j'ai pas forcément besoin qui développe
ses qualités de bollène links qualité de
création individuelle et collective et
je pense que ça peut être un souviennent
dit qui peut stopper les meilleurs
extérieur et les meilleurs elian n'diaye
retentiront en volume et ça me suffit
pour l'avoir très très haut qui s'y est
dit griffin ne retrouve pas ou plutôt ne
développe pas ses qualités de bolton
ling
quel est le style qui peut le faire
passer dans la catégorie qui peut lui
faire avoir quand même cette valeur d'un
top 5 de draft
est-ce que c'est défense sur le poteau
attaque est ce que ces
shoots après mouvement sortir des écrans
etc quel est le style précis sur lequel
il aurait besoin encore de progresser
qui peut faire de lui un joueur à haute
valeur tu as parlé de kayes thompson
il va devoir développer effectivement ce
onze son aisance dans le tir sa fluidité
dans une tir en sortie d'écran on a vu
que c'était un joueur qui avait des
appuis un peu particulier avec un écart
entre autres les les appuis pied paul
très très large c'est un joueur qui
était plus à l'est sur la finition mais
qu'ils avaient plus de difficultés
motrices aux habitudes motrice pour
poser le ballon une fois et tirer à
trois points ou pour pouvoir vraiment
feinte et la prise des grands soirs end
of et ensuite de dégainer est-ce que
clayton pour le coup fait excellemment
bien haut niveau moi j'ai pas de doute
sur sa défense et jean sont cuits soit
sa polyvalence et sur ses placements
mais faut pour être vraiment atop tiers
de la nba en dessous il faut vraiment
avoir beaucoup plus de polyvalence ont
trois points ouais et ça ça va passer
comme tu le dis par une modification des
habitudes motrices et peut-être voilà un
travail sur savoir planter l'appui
direct plus rapidement en direction du
cercle pivoter la piloter la hanche
directement quand tu passes après
l'écran pour pouvoir shooter sur sur un
parent fait juste ramener le deuxième
appui est montée directe comme clé
thompson le fait très bien derrière les
écrans a pas besoin de poser un dribble
en fait
ensuite on passe du coup à kendall brand
qui je pense fait partie de dés des
ailiers qui est 6e sur ton board qui sur
notre board commun est bien plus by 23e
quel est pour toi le la valeur ajoutée
immédiate de kendall brand
et qu'elle roulerait quel rôle il va
avoir tout de suite à une vie
aq khan dow jones un joueur qui a fait
une première ce fut une première et
dernière saison freshman abbey lors un
peu décevant dû quitter très attendu il
arrive dans une équipe très compétitive
donc on l'a un peu dévaluée je trouve
que sa capacité chercheurs trop les sons
sont créés haendel déjà et sa
polyvalence dans le dans la finition ou
les iops est vraiment trop importante et
donc je pense qu'il va arriver sur un
premier temps par effectivement du coin
du ballon ligne de fond où il est à
saint stoppa blé qui monte très haut qui
reste très longtemps en l'air et qui va
aussi poser des écrans loin du ballon ou
sur l'homme sur pick'n roll il va si on
n'a pas vu le côté de belfort qui va
pouvoir rouler poser un de ballons et
terminer avec grosse efficacité non qui
jouerait presque comme un intérieur mais
sur un poste peu déliées je vois au fur
et à mesure suscite chez ce joueur une
capacité à se créer son accès au cirque
par lui-même depuis le périmètre parce
que j'achète fort le dribble sur les
balbutiements sur les flashs qu'on ait
pu avoir dans une cuve et ça manque de
créateurs et c'est ça qui me le fais car
des très très très très haut par rapport
aux % social
à quel point il va devoir développer un
jumper pour pour pouvoir être jouable en
fait lors de phases finales par exemple
comme le disait ça va être très très
vite ciblé c'est que là jusqu'au all
star break les équipes vont pas
forcément faire l'impasse sur lui parce
qu'un peu de scouting je trouve sur les
jeunes qui arrivent surtout pour les
jeunes qui sont allés top 10 de la draft
ce qu'anders bonne même si moi je les
eaux ne voudrais pas être top 10 de sa
draft donc après le all star break qui
vont faire l'impasse et il va devoir
être plus le plus efficient rapidement
jeudi phie lui le problème c'est pas
particulièrement de mécanique pour moi
c'est pas un problème de confiance en
lui il a peu goûté au niveau lycéens est
là abbey lors il a refusé énormément de
tirs en deuxième partie de saison il en
prend beaucoup plus en tout cas il les
prend avec mois d'hésitations et on a vu
un jour plus libérés plus efficace dans
le catch and shoot donc je vais pas
attendre de la créativité jour du pool
up à trois points mais juste être
capable dans le corner de tirer et du
coup ça lui offrir aussi des lignes de
cut ligne de fond quand le défenseur
sera collée à lui on ne pas se prendre
la sanction côté faible donc ce qui
explique tonton classement de kendall
brand plus haut que le consensus ensuite
si on descend dans ton board hugon à
shenzhen chars et sheridan charroux je
ne sais pas si tu le classe comme en
wing bas alors tu vas dans ma liste la
gelée pas mis parce que pour moi à terme
ça va être un beau l'aisne l'eure un
créateur parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
création d'espacés création de tir donc
j'ai plus d'aspiration pour pour shannon
sharpe en tant que co bollène lors de la
même manière que je payais pas lebron
quiero qui joue pourtant je vois les
postes d'ailiers non une parce que voilà
j'ai ce jeu c'est expectations
joueurs alors créateur d'abord par
lui-même ce pas qui va être un bon
créateur collectif tout du moins dans
son année pendant son contrat rookie
mais c'est un joueur à qui je pense
qu'on va donner le ballon et on va lui
dire fais toi ta propre attaque et donc
ça me le fait basculer dans le
hockey c'est intéressant alors manu je
pensais un peu sur la même longueur
d'onde que toi concernant bang bang
héros puisqu'il a mis dans ces bollène
leur voler leur second
bollène l'heure quand même et
il l'avait pas mis celle de sharp alors
on a oublié jay de nardi on s'excuse
pour pour ce qu'il est et le potez
bolender c'est ma faute j'ai zappé j'ai
d'ailleurs dit mais mais moi celle d'une
charte par exemple je l'aurais mis
chez les ch et les ailiers
avec du beau lending c'est à dire le la
plus haute catégorie d'ailier en fait
qui ont déjà le shoot qui tous les
atouts pour défendre des 2 et 3
mai qui vont avoir
un développement à faire sur justement
ce bol en ligne et cette création pour
les autres c'est à dire arriver à poser
les pieds dans la raquette et du coup
alors ça peut être pour soi une fois
qu'on est dans la raquette mais ça peut
être aussi pour les autres gène sharp il
a déjà ce truc de se créer son espace
tout seul sur des steppes bas que des
side step il a toute la panoplie
nécessaire là dessus pour moi ça n'en
fait pas un bon n leur mets mais plutôt
une genre d'une sorte de zac lavine
toqués fans de chicago qui a pris petit
à petit en nba à un jouet des pick and
roll mais quand il arrivait c'était
surtout un gars qui qui shootait et qui
posait maximum on va dire trois dribbles
mais c'est ça après tu vois ça c'est un
truc qu'on se le dise souvent leur
honneur vous quand vous avez fait le
podcast avec alan ben sur eux sur les
bonnes alors je m'étais fait la même
remarque en vous écoutant parce que l'an
dernier vous aviez pas mis ce colis
barnes par exemple en tant que bonne
humeur là au moins je l'avais bonheur et
ce nom vous aviez dit
parce que je suis un fidèle auditeur au
plus d'être un membre aviez dit que à
terme il deviendrait bollène l'heure
mais que pour l'instant initialement
c'était pas un bollène l'euro en tout
cas un bollène l'orne négatif dans de la
créativité collective et même individuel
cholette deux premières années c'est une
limite qu'on va avoir pour pas mal de
joueurs c'est de savoir jusqu'où ils
peuvent remonter ça peut leur valoir
justement 8,9 place le sceau de la cuvée
bien sûr aidé à des franchises qui vont
les drafté pour être faire du bowling et
qui vont les sur drafté et inversement
il ya des joueurs qui vont pas être pris
pour ces qualités là elle tombe à dire
juste et dans un rôle de finition
d'action bien sûr c'est à dire ceux ya
souvent ce jeu là d'ailleurs la draft
approchant si vous deviez mix et enfin
rajouté un skill à un joueur en
particulier pour lui amener vraiment le
mot à dire le plus haut potentiel chez
de sharp c'est très facile de me dire tu
lui donnes le haendel de juba kennedy
chandler ou jean montéro un de ceux là
ensuite c'est pas très compliqué vu ses
qualités physique athlétique de toucher
etc
deron cybranet dante et bollène leur
j'imagine ouais ben oui c'est pour moi
c'est un pollen leur même exclusif alors
que c'est un des leaders sur le sur le
corps physique mais que sans le ballon
il sort quasiment rien et ce qui peut
pas être si il est mal utilisé selon ce
que feint pas utilisé comme cette année
et ce qui peut pas être est ce qui peut
pas faire partie justement des
décodeurs puisque c'est un joueur qui
perd même très puissant certes qui finit
bien
qu'ils aient large qui est puissant et
l'a pas trop fait
state donc pour le coup il avait il a eu
lieu toute l'année il a eu le ballon
dans les mains et quant à lui enlever
pour tes gavin smith on l'a mis dans un
corner alors qu'ils n'avaient pas un tir
à trois points développés ça s'est pas
très bien passé donc on pourrait
peut-être l'utiliser comme ça mais si tu
le prends pour ça en vrai le draft pas
en tout cas je le draft pas du tout
premier tour et même au second tour j'ai
du mal pour moi il faut lui donner le
ballon dans ses mains sinon il sert à
rien et j'ai un autre joueur qui
ressemble à ça - extrême mais c'est
johnny davis pour moi tu vois il les
champs mal limite donc hollande l'heure
où wings et si tu le prends pour faire
un wings ce que les peines pourraient
faire par exemple ben j'aime pas et le
savent alors elles baissent alors si tu
prends molène leurs bas je trouve bien
plus intéressant et ça lui fait monter
sa valeur chez moi alors juste présente
moi parce que les autres dont on a parlé
on avait déjà fait des podcasts dessus
des présentations johnny davis tu as
fait une vidéo évidemment
sur qu'est sur notre chaîne replay
youtube il me semble mais normalement
est ce que tu peux deux mètres de deux
mètres 8 d'envergure 89 kg sophomore
jouant oui ce qu'on assimile a explosé
pendant sa deuxième saison est passé de
7 à 20 points par match de 3 à 7 rebonds
de pardon de 4 à 8 rebonds il a doublé
son nombre de passes décisives et 2
balles perdues par la même occasion et
ils shootent moyennement bien quatre
tentatives à trois points par match pour
seulement 31 % de réussite mais 4 79%
lancers francs sur 6 tentatives par
match
johnny davis il est utilisé comme en
free et n'diaye ce qui peut quand même
avoir du succès ou est ce que pour toi
il manque un peu de tirs de variétés
choses urgentes
qu'il a montré cette année à wisques en
scène qui joue dans une équipe où il y
avait beaucoup de beaucoup de mouvements
avec beaucoup de joueurs expérimentés et
lui en fait avec ce rôle un peu ingrat
de lorsque le système capote bassée -
qui récupère un ballon et se créent du
pool up il n'a pas été très à l'aise en
catch and shoot et ça se voit donc plus
un jean maurice qui là qu'il a besoin de
poser un peu la balle au sol pour
pouvoir se crée son tir et même dans le
trois points 31% ces deux tiers avec une
passe décisive à dire que dans un tiers
des cas ils essaient de cresson tire
donc même là ils avaient besoin de poser
le ballon au sol pour revenir sur un
geste extérieur
loin du ballon je trouve que l'athlète
verticale est pas exceptionnel donc dans
le code c++ limitant la puissance c'est
pas non plus un rapide dans la campagne
et paniers et le catch and shoot il est
pas encore là défensivement il fera le
taf du soulier andy parce qu'il défend
très bien notamment les il est très
intelligent très investis
mais c'est un mec qui a quasiment mis
que du pool up notamment c'est en garde
ses tirs à mi distance parce que j'aime
bien élargir le tit re mi distance y a
que 8 % de ces tirs pris à 1100 qui sont
issus d'une passe décisive
donc c'est vraiment un joueur de poules
poulets bat john baker et j'aime bien le
comparer un peu à chris middleton danse
dans ce profil là même si remy knowlton
a montré par la suite un surtout même au
début pour s'installer en équipe était
capable de planter à gros volumes en
catch and shoot à trois points ouais
c'est la différence effectivement et et
c'est ce qui va c'est ce qui va faire ou
non le début de carrière de johnny davis
puisqu'il aura pas énormément la balle
entre les mains il aura pas énormément
mais si plantes
s'il arrive s'il parvient à utiliser ses
qualités athlétiques grâce à une menace
perçue au tir évidemment ça va lui
ouvrir des portes bien bien autres 11e
sur ton big board et en général il est
pareillement un petit peu plus au
huitième 8e essai les mighty oak trail
les neuf mais parce que personne ne l'a
mis plus bas que neuf en fait et on est
tous très homogène ce qu'on disait hier
soir contre elle avec les spurs on est
tous très homogène sur ce mec là oui et
c'est un des rares nos risques pour moi
norris prospects c'est à dire et peu
importe le contexte il va apporter même
s'il apporte pas énormément il va
apporter à leur égard peut-être pas à
porter comme un top ten pic est évident
mais il peut apporter
on a oublié membres de ton top 10 en
passant et après on fonctionnera
peut-être plus par groupe les groupes
que tu nous a décrit au début mais
jérémy soran lui va être à catégoriser
de la même manière que kendall brand new
pas c'est à dire les ce qui pose les
écrans les lecteurs finisseur qui ont
peut-être un autre potentiel que ça on
est totalement jetées dans la même
catégorie je sais que beaucoup de gens
parlent de la passe de jérémy sera né ce
qui est vrai c'est que c'est un joueur
très intelligent toujours bien placé
surtout défensivement en fait mais
offensivement on a on a vu qu'il y avait
un triple très très limité un dribble
très haut un premier pas ces moyens peu
de variations peu de tirs extérieurs
voire même pas de tir extérieur le catch
and shoot pour le coup la mécanique et
la fluidité ne sont pas là donc pour moi
on est sur un mec qui va devoir existé
lors de la pose d'écrans parce qu il le
fait déjà très bien vu qu'il a un
antécédent professionnel en ayant joué
dans des contextes soit équipe nationale
adultes soit à orange academy en
allemagne et qui s'est déjà posé des
écrans ont roulé écarter un clic et
finir main droite ma gauche et donc on
est vraiment plus sûr a fini sur
l'exclusif il n'y a pas assez de bollène
nîmes pau que je les en flux difficulté
engrenage pour moi
c'est un poste 5 de playoffs
il peut il peut totalement de cinq mois
début de la v me 3,4 windstopper et il
peut être post5 de playoffs il peut être
une sorte de de douane green si tout se
passe excellemment bien il peut être au
delà du fait de changer de coupe de
cheveux de couleur de cheveux tué deux
jours un dennis rodman alors moins
agressif mais avoir ce rôle un peu under
16 mai combattons toujours très bien
placé très bon rebondeur et voilà ça
peut ça fait exact exactement est
rarement un profil souhaité en plus
dans ce même moule donc mais plus bas
dans ton dans ton board qu'elle quels
sont les autres joueurs qui rentrent
dans ce moule de bombes a pour l'instant
ça choque pas trop mais il ya un vrai
profil athlétique pour pour défendre
pour poser des écrans et pour être
efficace vers le cercle j'en ai deux qui
me vient comme ça majoritairement gétaz
wilson
l'ailier de l'as les sioux qui est
sophomore et qui sort effectivement deux
de ces universités où la changer deux
des cols entre les deux faits cincinnati
pu et de soins sur le col et le rolland
quasiment d'une utilisation
ouais il arrive à aller jouer c1 c'est
le pyromane même s'il prend pas trop
texte permet en tout cas le l'atout
scoring sortie ben ali et meilleur
scoreur de son équipe en sortant du banc
avec 24 minutes de temps de jeu
seulement bête physique énorme défense
potentiel défensif xxl même si pour le
moment et un manque de maturité de
rigueur et il fait 6 fautes en 25
minutes j'exagère mais il fait 3 fautes
en en 24 minutes
mais le potentiel peut-être est un des
plus existence pour ça que certains
l'ont top 10 voire top 8 de la draft
parce que le le short roll est assez
incroyable et que s'ils développent un
tir extérieur
on peut avoir un joueur vraiment
excellent en biais pour les joueurs de
ce groupe le swing skill celui qui peut
les faire passer de joueurs à valeur
correcte à joueurs à haute valeur c'est
le sait le shoot où il y en a un autre
ouais je dirais quand même le shoot je
dirais quand même le foot parce que ça
t'ouvre bien plus de temps de jeu bien
plus de portes sachant que c'est alison
pour le coup tu as déjà un bout de
dribbler que pour moi c'est plus facile
d'acheter un tir en nba qu'un dribble
mois plus dans les choix qui développe
un tir cadré
l'exemple que j'ai sur les postes
d'ailier c'est alors même s'ils tiraient
mieux ressentant de fac mais mal
switches michigan state un énorme
athlète vraiment un
tank et un mais limité sur les doigts et
lee développement tirer à trois points à
charlotte avec un beau coup un volume
bien plus élevée ce qui lui permet de
montrer ses steels balle en main et sa
puissance et sa brutalité même en porte
nord du pick and roll et maintenant
c'est un joueur qui a été considéré dans
la cour sur le star game et qu'il a peut
prétendre un très beau contrat pour un
deuxième point
d'autant alors pour aller dans le sens
de ta reason par rapport à kendall brand
par rapport à jérémy soral il ya 1 80 %
aux lancers francs qui fait bien qui
fait très très bien même surtout quand
on voit la progression entre année 1 et
année 2 qui est extraordinaire il passe
de 57% sur deux tentatives par match à
80 % sur six tentatives par match au
niveau des lancers francs et même à 3
points à 36 % le volume est faible de
quatre tentatives par match mais
c'est pas un bon shooteur quoi taris
non je crois je crois plus dans le
cirque eux pour virer nissan par exemple
où je suis assez persuadé que ça se fera
pas dans son contrat rookie moi là
dessus j'ai en plus c'est si j'ai des
réserves sur le jour et que je les plus
bas
c'est la mentalité sur le terrain
c'est un joueur qui m'a montré en deux
ans qu'il n'a jamais écouté ses coaches
c'était des très mauvais coach et à
cincinnati elle est soumis les écoutez
pas quand l'idée passe le ballon à lui
tiré quand même et il ya une instabilité
dans voilà foot qui prennent en rigueur
sur le chemin à faire des fautes ne pas
se jeter dans les feintes ne pas vouloir
trop en faire et c'est ce qui me fait un
peu plus douter le signale à bhl il ya
la valeur de l'environnement toujours là
on parlait de brown et soan qui ont été
à baylor qui est une école de basket
ball on le répétera jamais assez mais
voilà
stricte et
structurée et les joueurs ne déborde pas
de leur cadre général même si ça empêche
pas de la créativité mais les joueurs ne
déborde pas de leurs cadres cincinnati
alors je le regardais pas trop à
cincinnati mais c'est pas connu non plus
pour être une fac formatrice et les
sioux c'est un joyeux bordel
depuis des années et cette dernière
saison en particulier d'ailleurs tout le
monde et pas retiré fin de la saison
soit mort et fusionner des problèmes
aussi extra sportifs
donc
ouais le code s'est fait virer enfin
tous les joueurs ont des comics comme on
dit bref donc il ya aussi peut-être
cette cet aspect là prendre en compte
sur taris saône mais pour le coup les
les inquiétudes sur la prise de décision
aux matchs sont réels tu disais avoir un
autre joueur danse ou la
cgt-cheminots tout moi c'est ça notre
situation non non ça c'est ma note
l'ailier de memphis le jamaïcain parce
que j'ai appris qu'il était jamaïcain
alors moi je l'avais noté américain mais
il a fait le u18 je crois avec la
jamaïque selanne qui m'avait trouvé ça
parce qu'il m'avait me trouver les stats
à trois ponts le joueur avait bien tiré
son équipe nationale alors qu'il a très
mal tiré à memphis alors qu'il sortait
du banc jeune joueur très très très
jeune pour le coup je l'appelle des
rickshaws 2.0 parce qu'on est sur un
profil filiforme longiline monté sur
ressort avec une polyvalence défensive
vraiment très excitante je trouve sur
les postes 2 3 4
un très bon passeur un vraiment très bon
passeur gelé paf l'unificateur parce que
le dribble est vraiment très mauvais
mais j'aime beaucoup les qualités de
passes dont je pense que pick and roll
je roule et je peux ensuite faire le le
bon choix ça j'aime beaucoup belle
finition près du panier est encore une
fois un tir à trois points a vraiment
stabilisé pour pouvoir exister en une
bielle
qui sont alors les fluidifie catr
puisque tu disais que c'était le profil
que tu valorise l plus par sa rareté et
par son efficacité aussi en nba
je veux donner du poids à différents
niveaux lors d'une éclipse en a déjà
parlé
je te fais une petite liste comme ça
ouais et turbo sur ce que tu veux j'ai
mis dedans
jovic le serbe j'ai mis john williams de
santa clara j'ai mis des landes théorie
dans les zones a qui gagnent mais parce
qu'il faut le mettre quelque part quand
même et j'ai voulu être sympa il m en
fluidifie sather quand même et ousmane
diagne
ok alors si c'est quand même intéressant
puisque sur tout ce que tu me cites manu
on a au moins trois en trois ou quatre
en ce qu'il appelle porteur de ballon
secondaires
donc ousmane diagne nicolas jovic
d'haleine terry il les a et
les as en porteur de ballon secondaire
on va parler d'eux du coup rapidement de
dalhem terry
qui moi je les regarde et je les monte
énormément dans mon bord j'ai regardé
récemment
m'a impressionné sur sur des flashs plus
qu'autre chose comment tu le vois déjà
est-ce que sa valeur à lui elle n'est
pas avant tout défensives c'est à dire
sur le poteau attaque on a vu que bas en
playoffs c'est quand même hyper
important ainsi totalement c'est un mec
de culte de maître puisqu'il a été re
mesurer à la hausse la 2 et de 0,4 à
2,04 ça au combat alors qu'on l'avait à
à 98 avant et on s'est donné parce qu'on
trouvait plus grande bénédicte mathurin
qui a montré qu'ils pouvaient défendre
sur les petits ultra rapide comme sur
les plus gros profils et en plus il a la
mentalité de sales gosses qui veut tuer
tout le monde
toujours à rentrer la tête de son but de
son attaquant toujours toujours bien
placé voilà toujours cette mentalité de
trash talking pour pour défendre
clairement ça son atout premier il est
défensif d'accord avec ça
et après offensivement il ya toi tu en
parles comme un un connecteur influent
édificateur parce que alors je vais
donner deux stats 22% à 6 seulement -2
17% de balles perdues ski
le meilleur ratio pour les joueurs que
tu as cité
ouais c'est un joueur qui alors qu'il
jouait dans une équipe d'arizona bien
léché être compétitive avec eux il y
avait en gros trois meneurs il y avait
les quarts crise à yahvé lui il y avait
belle ma témoins qui avaient peut-être
de rotation main il y avait à soulac du
belize qui jouait beaucoup de end of
donc ça jouait très très bien arizona et
donc ils étaient déchargés de ça ils
passent plutôt bien capable de passer
aux trois niveaux lobé sol direct un peu
de magie visuelle mais je trouve que le
dribble
est trop faible notamment dans le
changement des vitesses dans le
changement de direction donc ce soit
pour moi un créateur secondaire haut
niveau
peut-être que ça mais qui peut remonter
le ballon mettre un peu les choses en
place temporisé je t'aimais y sera
optimisée en jouant avec un deux voire
trois meilleurs bollène l'heure ça peut
être un joueur qui peut être parfait
dans des équipes qui ont lé ballon dans
les mains des ailiers ça ça peut être
heures et lui doivent défendre ça peut
être le scénario idéal pour son
développement lui est ce qu on a
une sorte de comparaison pour ce genre
de profil jeu j'aurais dit oui
bah tu vois on est toujours un peu de
forme et 16 à ce truc du mec qui joue
meneur qui défend les arrières et qui
peut switcher des ailiers qui peut
dribbler passer et chuté en cas de gêne
tout et être être efficace tu préfères
avoir sa queue mètres qui passe sur un
terrain je pense que le long 2 au bol
c'est le scénario ultra optimisme si
l'an 2000 avait beaucoup plus de
créativité à la passe et quand même plus
de dribbles ayew ciel bien sûr alors les
deux autres que manu a incité donc
ousmane diagne pour toi n'est pas le
plus d'attaqués là dessus pas un pas en
porteur de ballon pour toi il va
apporter de la valeur en tant que que
fluidifie catr connecteurs et du coup il
perd beaucoup de valeur c'est peut-être
pour ça que je n'ai pas aussi moins
important
c'est parce que j'ai bien aimé ce qu'il
a pu montrer dont justement lui le
changement de direction changement de
vitesse mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
un joueur qui va tout le temps manquait
de puissance qui va toujours manqué de
des capacités athlétiques à pouvoir
imposer son propre rythme et imposer son
corps au niveau supérieur et j'ai pour
le moment pas assez de toucher balle en
main notamment de la création de clubs
mi-distance trois points et même sur le
flotteur games pour avoir de façon très
crédible à un porteur de balle je lui
souhaite mais je suis assez pessimiste
sur ce scénario là ok on en reparlera
pansement sur lors du live sur les
chances des français a draft nicolas
jovic alors lui c'est quand même
intéressant parce que par rapport aux
autres bons et qui mesure deux mètres 12
et tu l'as mis quand même dans les
potentiels connecteurs
et on fait ça me chante mieux que les
autres tous les autres que tu sais ça
sont peu alors il ya une aide de choses
il ya le fait qu' on n'y a ni qu il
souligne une main gauche assez faible
moi j'ai trouvé ça plutôt rassurant
cette année la main gauche
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il va être
drafté plus bas
que peut-être des mecs ont assité qui va
peut-être d'être achetés en bordure du
top 20 on va pas lui demander de tenir
le ballon au départ et qui va devoir
exister majoritairement comme un
fluidifie catr genre un rôle en sortie
de banc de de joker de scoring est ce
que quelque chose m'a fait au fur et à
mesure et du coup je
dans une équipe compétitive pour moi
c'est plus un mec qui peut marquer des
paniers qui peut dépanner sur plein de
situations mais qui est pas un porteur
de balle j'ai la rage avait valu manger
avait donné à manu la comparaison alors
très facile en fait née honte
de bojan bogdanovic en termes de rôle
arrive et pour moi vos jeunes enfin
comme on arrive aux jeunes alors autant
parce que moi je confonds tout en
bougeant mondial je vous dirais oui
ouais plus puissant plus polis mais bo
gen est ce que c'est un créateur
secondaire pour toi babeau jeunes je les
ai déjà vus jouer des pick and roll je
l' ai déjà vu mais je les ai déjà vus
surtout être un connecteur en fait comme
tu dis tu vois surtout de bien qui est
un connecteur et lui il va plus être un
connecteur en puissance plutôt qu'en
technique geovic ça va être plus sur la
technique et la taille aux jeunes ça va
d'avantagé sur walf un dribble fort
j'arrive à déloger un peu mon adversaire
a continué à le décalage qui a été créé
pour moi mais
on sache 2g d'accord je suis d'accord
avec ça et en fait tous les mecs dont
haas était là c'est pas parce que je dis
connecteur qui pourront pas de tendance
en jouant un pick and roll elle aime
tous les mecs je sais que là vont
pouvoir jouer un pick and roll sauf que
pour moi ya pas un système qui dit qui
commence en tout cas à part on joue un
pick and roll pour que tu trouves une
passe ouverte ou que tu m'aurais même
mais plutôt ja renversement engine fin
de systèmes sa capote un petit peu bas
vient je t'appelle le [ __ ] l intérieur je
peux poser le ballon et profiter de
l'écran et trouver une solution mais on
se base pas sur leurs qualités
intrinsèques à créer du jeu collectif en
première intention bien sûr on est
d'accord
alors pourquoi j'ai ouvert j'ai lyn
williams et je ne sais pas il ne sait
pas parce que cette chaîne que j'avais
moi qui sont jamais à côté c'était juste
à côté saint jean ce message d'accord on
m'a mise à jour alors john williams ça
c'est intéressant puisque c'est un nom
qui monte donc forcément on a un peu
moins parler que les autres peut-être
cette saison joueur de santa clara qui a
une une grosse taille pour toi c'est
quoi sa porte d'entrée dans la nba
pour moi c'est un top 3 défenseurs
ailier de sa de sa cuvée avec auch aiac
badji
et jerry finn jeremy seront aussi à côté
nouvelle assez dans le top 15 donc c'est
un des meilleurs défenseurs
qui a défendu plus grand cette année en
acier que femme plus petit prénom que sa
taille parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'extérieur à santa clara je les ai vus
défendre des pick and roll et j'ai vu un
joueur qui est capable de traverser des
écrans porter ou non porter qui fait un
travail de scouting jour ses adversaires
remarquable à chaque fois il sait qui
peut tirer en sortie d'écran ont sorti
de l'équipe de régler main droite main
gauche
c'est un mec qui a des voilà des
fondements défensive vraiment
exceptionnel et qui en plus montre un
volume à trois points sur trois
tentatives avec une belle efficacité
faut voir si petit rappel ou voulu mais
moi j'en ai eu que des échos positifs et
enfin qui est un vrai frais très bon
passeur qui a pu jouer du pick and roll
mais qui est vraiment un excellent
passeur pour sa paye
absolument plus quatre passes de moyenne
cette saison avec seulement
2,1 balles perdues certes c'est une plus
petite conférence donc il a eu des
matches un peu plus facile mais cette
année il y avait il ya vait du niveau
dont l'un des but you see sea donc ce
n'était pas forcément évident est donc
d'autant plus de crédit à être un bon
défenseur que il avait quand même
supporter 25 % de taux d'usagé ce qui
par extraordinaire c'est pas déjà mort
en test kamerhe state mais c'est ça veut
dire qu'il avait le ballon entre les
mains comme tu comme tu l'a expliqué
qu'ils gagnent murray donc que tu ne
classe pas dont parmi les bovins de
leurs évidemment non pas parmi les les
intérieurs non plus
quel est son rôle idéal qui gagnent
murray
de base pour moi il ya un truc qui va
faire très bien c'est posant des grandes
pick and pop il va exceller là dedans
parce qu'il a un très bon tir et qu'il
ya une fluidité pour pour déclencher ce
geste là
et j'ai voulu le mettre en fut difficile
à tort parce que même si j'en ai dû
plutôt du mal ce toute l'année
parce qu'on a dû quand même un mec qui
fait toujours les bons choix ballon j'ai
l'impression que c'est un gars qui a
toujours faire la bonne passe qui va pas
essayer de croquer qui vit peut proposer
plus que simplement tirer ou finir près
du cercle lors qu'un athlète à ses
moyens donc j'ai envie de croire que ce
mec-là bien utilisé peut vraiment
fluidifier du jeu et on est sur un
profil tard je parlé d'auto porter enfle
édificateur l'on pense pas tellement à
lieuran pas entendre d'engrenages mais
qui fait tout sur un terrain de la pose
d'écrans du renversement de la lecture
est qui qui rend vraiment une attaque
meilleur sur l'homme est loin du ballon
donc c'est pour ça que je devais faire
entrer dans cette catégorie là notre
mexicaine mais j'aime bien la
comparaison avec peut-être en plus
d'autos porteur du fait de son rôle en
haïti est son passé une capacité à punir
les match up de personnes plus petit que
lui il est injuste il a il a cette
faculté avoir des appuis forts de près
la stat impressionnante évidemment qui
gagnent leur est pour un joueur qui
marque 23 points par match c'est qu'il a
moins de 6% de ballons perdus parce que
je sais pas c'est déjà vu ça chez l'un
chez un prospère à haute utilisation au
volume en ligne et on a fini avec les
connecteurs ubuesque à un peu plus bas
dans ta draft qui a qui manque peut-être
une petite un petit truc pour être
connecteurs mai mais qui peuvent l'être
voilà à la volette je te dirais qu'on a
fait le tour et puis si jamais en
mention à la fin je lâcherais desfire
boulette sur le compte commun au maroc
et des demoiselles à l'ensemble ap john
watson moi le problème c'est notre santé
que j'ai quasiment rien vu ou si elle
est donc pas large à rien vu à ucla
donc je me base plus sur du lycéen sur
deux aujourd'hui 19 et lui pour le coup
j'ai l'impression qu'il apporte que ça
en fait que de la queue de la passe la
lecture mais qu'il n'y a rien ou pas
grand chose en finition n'y a pas grand
chose dans le tir extérieur donc je suis
pas fan du profil donc c'est pas moi qui
vais être le mieux placé pour pour
défendre le garçon tongs et
donc il nous reste les louis andy
classique on va lire alors donc
j'imagine que tu as au tchad bagis
j'essaie de devinettes tu as peut-être
ben mathurin ouais moi je pense que là
tu as tu as peut-être wendell moore
sinon je vois pas où tu pourrais l'avoir
aloud amour aussi
peut-être pas de baldwin ouais je
l'aimais la
gestion bonnes mares john butcher
ouais je les ai mis la même si je suis
quand même pas trop culture du joueur et
calais vieux stade
j'ai calé juste tonnes et puis après
j'ai des noms un peu plus
et juste malakai malakai branham tue
mais
non je le milan le milan ac est gelé sur
troisième journaliste là ok ok alors
commençons par lui parce que il va être
dit va être top 20 enfin sauf surprise
il va être top 20 toi tu l'a 36
c'est un joueur qui a shooté de manière
assez extraordinaire au niveau des
chiffres cette saison du côté des eaux à
wayaux state qui a eu beaucoup de mal à
aller au cercle c'est ce que tu
reproches principalement trois lancers
tentés seulement par match papa beaucoup
de tirs de près mais dans les
pourcentages bas c'est quand même plus
de 50% à 2 points +2 40% à 3 prendre
plus de 80% dans ses frais
donc lui sa porte d'entrée donc lui pour
toi son rôle ça va être du tir et du
coup tu le fais un petit peu des cendres
donc on reinking c'est ça le seaway ce
qui me le faut ce qui me fait baisser
c'est que je trouve que ça des dribbles
est plus faible dans les mails dont a
parlé ce soir
vraiment je trouve que le dribble est
vraiment très mauvais pour l'accès au
panier et que dès que tu mets un peu de
contacts dessus ils paniquent is a raté
un tir ce qu'il fait très bien c'est un
excellent tir auront pour l'apa
mi-distance
vraiment très impressionnant et le
deuxième chose qui me le fait de baisser
c'est que le joueur se voit comme un bol
en pleurs
il était au lycée on discute avec manu
il était au lycée
ouais bah ça je suis pas trop surpris ce
que j'avais vu dans les interviews qui
sont passés lors c'est quand ils ont
fait les le combat il y avait des
petites interviews encore death à aider
tout ça l'idée est qu'il avait le ballon
dans les mains et que vous voyez bien la
voir au niveau d'après et je vois pas
dans quel monde ça peut arriver en nba
si son dribble e n'évolue pas
drastiquement et les joueurs qui ont une
image d'eux-mêmes qui pour moi ne n'est
pas cohérente avec la réalité
ça me les faits beaucoup baissé parce
que j'ai peur que ce soit des mecs qui
ont du mal à dessus du mal à s'adapter
en nba qui trouvent pas leur rôle et qui
du coup sous performé disparaissent
c'est pour ça que je vais peut-être
beaucoup plus bas que le consensus
malgré les qualités de tirer je pense
que le tir à trois points malgré les
deux tirs par match seulement ça va ça
va augmenter et les qualités défensives
peut-être pas aussi emballé que tout le
monde sur la polyvalence du mec par
contrôle pointent of attaques pourraient
exister à côté d'un second bollène fin
d'un volet de leur fort et du coup
devrait faire les missions défensives
que ce mec-là fais pas ça me semble tout
à fait cohérent on notera quand même la
7e place accordée à malakal branham par
le grand alan guillou
exil non mais les disparités sont
importantes c'est un pas qui divise
c'est intéressant parmi le reste du
groupe comment comment tu différencie
les uns des autres
vas-y il ya des shooteurs de très très
très haut volume il ya les mecs donc je
sais que ça va marcher qui ont plus
plein de tyrans répertoire notamment
auch aiac badji bénédicte mathurin jugé
très haut et un peu plus bas je vais
avoir des mecs si on est sur les cas un
peu plus folklorique genre jamal kenny
goss big one etc ou qu'elle nous ait dit
non plus de tyrans répertoire et après
je vais avoir les gars qui de base
avaient estaing qui espérait être des
baux l'aisne l'eure et qui sont devenus
des souliers n'diaye donc va falloir
confirmer ses habitudes motrices là je
sors du choix du très gros volumes
ok donc aux tchèques bagis qu'il a de
plus que les autres c'est celle-là
saison qu'il sort au tir qui est
extraordinaire
enfin que l'extraordinaire qui est très
très bonne 40 +2 40% à 3 points +2 50% à
2 points un bémol aux lancers francs
avec seulement 2 74% de réussite
c'est ça quand tu dis variété qu'est ce
que tu veux dire par variété ben ça un
jour qui peut pour l'exemple d'auchan
qui peut tirer soit autour de la fin de
chaîne donc vraiment je suis à l'arrêt
mais mal sont prêtes et j'étais gagnent
en catch and shoot qui peut sortir des
écrans donc je prends un système de
floppy classe queen et c'est là où j'ai
une course et je me réac ce vers le
panier et je peux tirer rapidement
capacité à poser un ou deux dribbles au
sol si le défenseur se jette donc là zot
et pour pouvoir retirer un deuxième
attention et puis jouer avec les écrans
jour sur des neuf
pouvoir justement perturber la défense
et pour des profils un peu plus grands
coaches et avec bungie est ce que tu es
tu peux poser un écran et faire du pick
and pop parce que c'est encore un tir un
peu particulier la spécialité de patrick
baldwin ou s'ils gagnent leurs aides en
apprennent un peu plus tôt ouais
ben mathurin on lui donne à peu près le
même arsenal simplement tu trouves qui
va un peu moins bien au cercle c'est ça
et on croit que quatre sur lui donc
c'est pas ça c'est un match où on se
voit comme important de balle mais il a
dans ses interviews il a fait que ça
aussi je vais porter le ballon j'ai
porté le ballon et il a pas il n'a pas
les dribbles n'a pas la passe il a pas
la créativité pour pour être ça donc
j'ai très peur d'eux j'ai très peur de
l'échec c'est pour ça qu'il est bien
plus bas que tout et si jamais se disait
chien un swing dit élite
je le mettrais plus haut et il peut
vraiment être à des meilleurs de la nba
dans ce rôle là au niveau supérieur
ensuite wendell moore au niveau de la de
la diversité de tir on va rester là
dessus
qu'est ce qu'il a de moins que ocha
ouendan moore il a moins le fait de
pouvoir sortir des écrans c'est plus un
catch and shoot heures de de ce pôle up
de fin de chaîne mais pour moi un écart
un petit peu entre la main droite et la
main gauche ou makoun récupère le ballon
sur sa main gauche c'est plus difficile
pour lui de réac c'est de tirer et
naturellement là où chaque batterie
comprend bien le jeu et sait se replacer
par rapport aux importantes de balai par
rapport à l'angle de passe wendell mort
est un peu plus de difficulté c'est un
truc qu'il a travaillé sur trois ans
mais c'est moins naturel pour lui ou
s'il est dans le dans le corner et ben
qui au lieu de se remettent à 45 degrés
on est un peu plus hésitant donc voilà
il ya moins de la moins de fluidité
pas de baldwin encore un petit peu moins
l'appareil on a fait un podcast sur lui
donc on vous renvoie là dessus mais
en gros seins pour moi c'est un shooteur
jusque j'appelle nord-sud
c'est à dire c'est un gars qui
ci reçoit la balle en trailer ou si
comme tu disais en pick and pop il est
excellent parce que parce que son tir
part au parce que ses appuis sont bien
posés maintenant sur la latéralité sur
les side step ou plutôt que les step
back qui va être alors qu'il a un stade
bac même s'il pas très mobiles mais il
n'a pas trop de saïd c'était donc ça va
être plus là dessus et puis évidemment
un peu moins de
défense sur sur les sur les ailiers que
ceux précédemment cités on à christiane
brown
alors ça ça m'intéresse on va y passer
une petite minute sur christiane brown
coéquipiers de tchèque bat j qu est-ce
qu il admis qu'est ce qu'il a de moins
selon toi pour se retrouver donc une
quinzaine de places plus loin
as un peu tous étaient là un an de moins
que chez avec badji même à kansas c'est
un joueur qui pour le coup est un peu
plus latéralisé toujours son tir même
s'il a dû tire aussi en sortie d'écran
en tout cas dans le dos de la course est
sa moins bonne omelette en général c'est
un moins bon finisseur près du panier
voilà c'est un joueur qui fait tout bien
mais qui sera un bon rôle player ou au
niveau supérieur là pour auchan et moi
j'ai désespoir le plus important parce
que le mec a commencé le basket très
tard et s'est développée christiane
brownies j'ai aucun doute sur le fait
qu'il ait plusieurs contrats donc on
pour évaluer ça un peu plus haut dans la
draft c'est juste que ça va être un
attrait borloo perd toute sa carrière et
il a une envergure négative c'est un peu
le séjour acceptable de la cuve est donc
allé comment s'appelle en verdure je
fais du 1er tour place pour une une des
particularités souvent des bons
shooteurs ce que plus le plus le bras et
court - il alla - il à la place d' aller
de travers si on pourra dire j'avais
l'exception bien sûr
calais be used ans oui ou stan je crois
contre le canadien dit austan
joueurs de michigan qui est un peu plus
grand que tout ce qu'on a cité taille
voilà il fait pas une bonne saison mais
tu vois la dernière fois je regarde un
peu de films et je passais sur les stats
évidemment ils jouent mal à deux points
très mal faut dire que space in game ici
à michigan n'était pas non plus la
panacée
mais il fit qui pose 35% à 3 points sur
5 tentatives 5 18% ses francs pour un
freshman c'est bien
moi et puis c'est un mec qui a montré
sur 4chan shoot
qu'il allait être efficaces ces trois
points c'est quasiment que du catch and
shoot et il a souffert tu le dis
michigan aspect singh et puis un système
de jeu assez complexe où la dumas il a
eu du mal à trouver sa place perd la vue
des deux côtés du terrain et il ya une
montée en puissance c'est jusque encore
une fois c'est un joueur qui avait été
annoncé comme un porteur de balle et qui
a déçu et du coup sa cote elle est
descendue peut-être trop descendu moi ce
qui me fait le dévaluer s'est passé ça
c'est qu'il fait une panne bonne saison
qu'il a montré des limites athlétiques
et qu'elle a monté des limites dans le
dribble dans les choix de jeu il attaque
beaucoup la haine de fond ils sont
ferment des données dans des petits
espaces alors qu'il n'a pas le dry prg
pour s'en sortir mais j'ai pas de doute
sur le fait qu'il se soit un bon tireur
à trois points au haut niveau à une
bille
oui je suis d'accord dans les choix de
jeu et moi même moi j'ai un titre est
plus là dessus que que sur les autres
problèmes comment tu le juge
défensivement en quelques mots
ben le il a un corps il a un corps est
vraiment intéressant
perdu dans les écrans je trouvais
l'iconnect pas il suffit pas il fait pas
d'effort il fallait prendre un peu dans
les écrans par contre de la défense
dédié j'ai pas de problème là dessus une
fois que que la tête et que la
compréhension du jeu suivra le reste
ok
marjane beauchesne alors effectivement
finalement regarde but n'est pas
d'accord et on l'a à la même place je
les 34 tu as 30 cents
j'apprécie lâchez moi ouais ils les
tuent la un peu descendu alors il est un
peu plus vieux que tous les prospects
qui jouait en j league il est avec lui
après il a un parcours voilà
storytelling les américains aiment bien
il était à l'agonie il ya deux ans
sortait de choco et là il est dans la
green room
1,99 de 13 d'envergure pour toi c'est
plus un défenseur qu'un shooter est ce
que tu crois vraiment son tir
je crois dans le tir je crois dans le
tir parce que j'ai vu du mi distance en
fluidité je tendais dans des zones
chantilly fait seuls jeunes peur et j'ai
aimé ce que j'ai vu il avait mieux tiré
dans l'est dans les programmes un peu
inférieure une façon assez aléatoire et
on sait que le niveau de la duke aux
voilà ça vaut ce que ça vaut je suis pas
du tout expert là dessus mais il a pu
montrer nerveux stade reste sourde et
sur d'autres parcours défensivement très
très impliqué un très bel athlète moi je
vois tout de suite il peut poser des
écrans il peut couper loin du ballon
il a failli et dont le profil e athlète
tu vois qu'on avait tout à l'heure avec
les soeurs anne braun et ouais c'est
juste que je trouve qu'il a un peu plus
de ce qu'ils un peu partout et que je
visualise bien un gars qui s'en sort
bien par la suite et notamment jour de
la pose des grands
ok ça c'est intéressant c'est pas qui
lui c'est pas quelque chose qui est
souvent dit quand on projette
ensuite je te donne ben voilà de là
plutôt des cartes carte blanche pour
pour citer les joueurs qu'on n'a pas
cité qui selon toi tous appartiennent
aux moules fui ndi où est ce qu il yad
autres des connecteurs d
[Musique]
pour un harper junior est un
vrai que j'ai assez que j'ai une que
j'aimais beaucoup de l'an dernier parce
que au delà du fait que ce soit le fils
de ron harper et que je vends des bulls
et tout mais c'est un jour très puissant
très tank et qui a un tir qui part au
sol mais assez fiable qui a fait une
[ __ ] une belle somme dresse avec des
responsabilités
qui avait fait peu d'efforts aux robots
en dernier mais cette année si amy et je
pense que lui peut arriver et tout de
suite joué parce qu'il aura pas de
problème d'adaptation physique renard
peur donc je suis assez serein et puis
en plus il a un papa ancien joueur nba
donc la transition professionnelle
devrait bien se passer pour le joueur tu
as mis jamal kane
il y a une mauvaise saison à trois
points mais qui ont carrière à 35 % 75 %
aux lancers qui joue à marquette et qui
a décidé de transférer pour sa cinquième
année
oakland à auckland
oui c'est un c'est un joueur qui était
le rôle player de marc catalan sait déjà
pas ou peut-être un rôle paieront une
sieste
appelé les plus grosses missions
défensives et qui tirait le jour de la
shoah de la finition et puis ont changé
de coach xhaka smart le terrible a
repris les rênes il s'est fait pousser
des cheveux et puis l'a repris les rênes
du coaching de marquette et lui il est
parti à auckland parce qu'il voulait
montrer que c'était plus qu'un rôle
player et c'est devenu la star
d'auckland ce qui explique aussi les
pourcentages à trois points plus bas
parce que c'était vraiment la seule
menace aux français de l'équipe mais
j'ai un joueur qui peut tirer partout
qui peut poser des écrans que jours qui
peut être en pick and pop qui a montré
une capacité à serait axé dans laxe à
sera axée vers le panier pour tirer et
qui défensivement je le projette pour
défendre du poste 2 3 4 et qui sait
aussi jouer les mismatch poste bas avec
un fadeaway et des fondamentaux donc
voilà un joueur un peu sous les radars
mais si on lui donne sa chance j'ai pas
de doute ça se passe bien et tu me
demandes être à l'heure à la volée les
joueurs peut-être
facilitateur de jeu sur les ailiers je
t'avais dit si je retrouve un bond
market ça me fait penser à justin des
oui oui le l'ailier qui a eu beaucoup de
ballons poulies assez anachronique parce
que joueur post-bac joueur très puissant
qui est quasiment un beau l'aisne l'eure
à la fac mais je vois plus être un
facilitateur de jeu au niveau une somme
de grains williams du pauvre ouais ouais
j'aime bien la comparaison j'aime bien
la comparaison très puissant très boudy
capable de tirer je pense qui tirera
mieux à trois points au fur et à mesure
de sa carrière défensivement pas
toujours impliqué mais les outils sont
là pour pour être un bon gros relous
très fort rebond de randers eyes donc ça
peut être ça peut être un très bon jour
de rotation qui fluidifie équine qui
peut dépanner je re sur un match dans la
création parmi tous ceux qui restent on
manque de temps mais je les cite tu me
dis tu me diras si l'on manque en agate
brown qui est un délice yu zhang li max
christique et vendredi
j'imagine que tu mettes germaine samuel
dans ce lot bref je nai covivo de justin
moore tu as sherman jeu même pas six
candidats
voilà après il ya quelques il ya
quelques mecs qui sont pas candidats
voire cuisant
ambages les amis tout en bas j'essaie de
sup de supprimer des trucs mais je
descends john wilson ont connecteurs
mais je sais pas sûr qu'il reste
finalement mais il a fait le combat nook
là dessus vous je vérifie bonjour j'ai
aussi un connecteur donc parmi tous ceux
que j'ai cités qui est le meilleur
shooteur qui est le shooteur qui va
apporter directement
par an par ces gens j'adresse diversité
il y en a deux s'il est ce qu'on va tout
le monde le meilleur histoire au canada
parce que je suis un rôle où michael des
veaux et quillan hugo il dit évoquant un
profil un peu plus petit vous avez dit
un peu plus grands un peu plus
athlétique moins bon créateur moins bon
passeur mais de spécialistes qui je
pense vont cartonner
michael de vaud que tu me fais plaisir
de m 53 c'est beau mais moi je lai en
dehors du top 60 une obsession du gobé
s'en était classé chez bollène leur par
manu sera ma dernière question toi tu le
classe
là où tu août une voix plutôt un bon
fruit ndi du coup même si bon il défend
pas trop bah ouais voilà c'était le même
problème que johnny toulousain eq c'est
que c'est un peu des mecs à part ça les
mecs c'est le pyromane et je voudrais
que je le préfère en souvienne dit pour
moi hugo besson
je vais être assez négatif et je suis
désolé pour la communauté française mais
c'est un mec qui va vivre et mourir en
mettant des cartons ce qu'ont pu être
des
débats emmanuel coux qu il le fait très
bien je ne les fais très bien il ya
tellement de scénarios ça marche pas
comme ils s'appellent avec des rythmes à
peut-être qu'il se pose une colle
alonso trilles un alonso très remercie
et moi j'avais un gag aussi qu'ils
sentaient de lait sur le feu par tous
mes mots qui ressemblait à black m et
voilà c'est des gars très gros profils
ce corps mais j'y crois pas donc je
l'aimais nulle part ouais mais il est là
dans ton sport je les classe de les
classer
absolument donc moi mon préféré de tout
ce que tu as cité même si ainsi gelé mis
trente de ses clones ellis ses joueurs
de l'alabama qui finit fort la saison et
qui est long je trouve excellent
vraiment excellent en défense qui est
chiant quoi ils ont ils un peu au ce et
tous là et
et puis qui shoote bien en fait très
très bien et alors après on bénéficie
toujours du système quand on est à la
base c'est comme ça
ce jeu à cette forme bien que tous les
mecs ont assité c'est pourquoi c'est
d'accord pour nous tous les mac os
c'était la plupart peuvent avoir une
tranche sur les shooteurs une très belle
carrière nba qu'en fait ça va être
vraiment le contexte il va jouer bien
parce que globalement tous ces mecs là
on pas une grosse cote parce que pas
énormément de talent et déjà des
spécialistes mais tous pourris pourrait
jouer et être les surprises dans des
équipes très compétitives et c'est pour
ça que moi sur ces joueurs là ce qui va
faire la différence finalement ça va
peut-être plus est la défense moi dira
si je sais que le gars enfin tu vois tu
prenais l'exemple même on a en fait on a
l'exemple dr john cette année même très
murphy qui est du temps de jeu bon les
deux dans la même équipe mais
si tu si tu défends fort le point se
battent à coups étaient vraiment
performant en défense collective
bah en fait tu vas avoir l'occasion de
montrer que tu peux rentrer et et tire
mais si tu défends site apporte pas
vraiment en défense tonton apport
immédiat ça va être juste entre
guillemets de space le jeu ce qui ce qui
est limité quoi ça moi je te rejoins
tour jean
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai plutôt
qu'ils analysent dans la fourchette
haute mac christie aussi moqueries steve
et tu n'as minul par jay clara via je
suis vraiment
c'est un truc que j'ai clara via ont pu
cesser de ma conférence maintenant donc
honte à moi médias que la radio qui qui
a très bien performé interdit au combat
et qui pour le coup lui avait là d'être
c'est sûr d'avoir une place top 30 mais
c'est un joueur voilà comme jill à edel
que moi je suis même pas sûre d'avoir
placé auxquelles je crois pas
particulièrement et qui est très coté
donc ce seront des mecs qui ont sur
lesquels on pourra me cherchais
à cames et je prendrai le chai avec
l'humidité et ce sera mérité
bon mon hugo on a on n'a pas fait un
tour exhaustif mais on a été assez
complet donc on se retrouve le soir de
la draft fonds se retrouve même avant
pour pour les live avant draft et puis
le soir de la draft en live on aura
romain sur bin manu et alan sur sur
steam et nous en filigrane qui animeront
le tout on sera sûr twitch youtube on
est en train de régler tout ça
est ce que tu as une chose à ajouter sur
les conseils peut-être pour les futurs
prospects liés
bah là ils sont dans une année une
énormément donc
jeudi serait jusqu'à mais quand qui va
être pris les gens en neuf points 17 on
33 ya pas forcément un gros écart de
suez cette année je pense que beaucoup
de gens vont crier au style alors que
c'est juste normal vu la drave on va
espérer que votre franchise a senti le
bon coup et que vous ayez le meilleur
whincup a remis parmi tous les nuggets
cela qu'ils sont là le style perçu et le
style réel
le prochain débat allez bisous - hugues
ont clos cet épisode et on se retrouve
très bientôt vous pouvez vous je vais
mettre tous les
les fiches toutes les fiches des
prospects dont on a parlé donc vous
aurez des scouts in report à lire en
même temps qu'ils écoutaient ou alors
après pour pour ce podcast visuel tout
le monde ciao ciao